let's start with this a tweet from corey
bush representative cory bush
let's remember that she is an elected
representative she's she is a member of
congress
and here's what she tweeted
she said when we marched in ferguson
white supremacists would hide behind a
hill near where michael j jr michael
brown jr was murdered and shoot at us
they never faced consequences
if kyle rittenhouse gets acquitted it
tells them that even seven years later
they still can get away with it
i mean
where do you even begin here how where
do you start
um
this isn't even the most important point
but what do you mean hid behind a hill
i'm trying to figure the figure out the
the physics of that exactly logistically
how does that work they're hiding behind
a hill
and shooting at you and this is
this is in the in the middle of the city
there's a big
hill that they can hide i'm trying to
imagine how that even works and i can't
but of course it doesn't have to work in
reality because she completely made this
up
i mean
when did this happen exactly
is there any evidence of this so there
were there were whites there were armed
white supremacist militants in ferguson
after uh michael brown was killed and
that by the way also
an entirely justified shooting
and that was also vindicated by local
authorities and the federal government
under the which at the time was under
the direction of barack obama barack
obama's
uh
doj
tried to find a way to
uh
you know tried to find some charges to
hang on the officer in that case
and couldn't find them
but yet they still use the michael brown
case
as an example
of police brutality and white
supremacist violence and all this kind
of stuff
a democratic administration
already debunked that
and they still use it
because the truth is irrelevant to them
of course
um
but she says that after this happened
there were there were militant white
supremacists on the scene shooting at
people
and this never made the news the media
decided not to report this fact
were they shouting this is mega country
while they shot maybe
uh but of course this is a brazen lie
from a from a
a sitting u.s congresswoman but she lies
brazenly because she knows she'll get
away with it
she knows that there is
there's no possible consequence to her
because she's a democrat
and also because of all of the identity
politics
points that she that she can check off
as a black woman so
you know that gives her all the cover in
the world and she could she could say
whatever she wants
nobody will follow up no one in the
media will even ask her about this
and that and that tells you everything
you need to know that that shows that
they know it's a lie because if they
thought there was any chance that this
actually happened
then they'd want to talk about it
they'd want to get her in front of a
camera and say tell us all about this
horrible experience with white
supremacists shooting at you
but they know it's totally bogus and so
they're not going to ask her about it
and of course we haven't even gotten to
the fact that she connects kyle
rittenhouse she puts him in the same
category as white supremacists
when
that's
just a flat out lie once again
but also everybody involved in this case
is white
they're all white people
i just saw there's another tweet from i
don't have it in front of me but
some blue check leftist someone in the
media saying saying that employers after
the kyle rittenhouse verdict comes down
no matter what the verdict is
this guy on twitter is saying that the
employers should give black employees
the day off give them a couple days off
you know because of how emotional this
case is for the for the black employees
what
black people there's there are no there
are no black individuals involved in
this case this is a white person who
shot three other white people
who are attacking him
but it doesn't matter the truth is the
truth is completely irrelevant um
and that is really what they that's
that's what they think this is ends
justify the means
the truth is uh you know the truth is
subjective
so the way they look at it with kyle
rittenhouse yeah there's of course he's
not a white supremacist
uh race has nothing to do with this case
whatsoever because everybody involved is
the same race
but the truth that's you know that might
be the truth that might be the reality
but it's not their reality it's not
their truth
and their truth is determined by how
they feel
and so they when they see this case it
feels to them like kyle rittenhouse must
be a white supremacist
and it feels to them like he's guilty of
mass murder
and because they feel that that's the
case then then it is the case then it's
true if you feel it then it's true
that's how they see it
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated